IN THE SPIN ROOM LATER ON IN THE
BROADCAST.
WE HAVE AN ALL-STAR LINEUP
TONIGHT.
WE HAVE RUDY GIULIANI,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY.
WE'VE GOT MIKE HUCKABEE, 2016
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
WE HAVE MARK PENN, McGRATH
POLSTER, FORMER CLINTON ADVISOR.
SARA CARTER, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND WRITER.
SO MANY GREAT TOPICS.
TO YOU RUDY, DID ANY DEMOCRAT
INTIMATES DEBATE EMERGE IN
YOUR MIND AS A VIABLE CHALLENGER
TO TRUMP?
TAKE YOUR REPRESENTATION OF THE
PRESIDENT OUT OF IT FOR A
MOMENT, JUST AS AN OBSERVER.
>> WHAT I REALLY FELT THE TAKE
AWAY FROM TONIGHT'S DEBATE WAS,
SANDERS AND WARREN DEFINED
THEMSELVES AS VERY, VERY
RADICAL, FISCALLY IRRESPONSIBLE
LEFT-WINGERS.
I THOUGHT THE ATTEMPT OF THE
MODERATES TO KIND OF GIVE THEM A
LITTLE ROOM TO MOVE A LITTLE
TOWARD THE MIDDLE -- IF YOU JUST
ADD UP, LET'S TAKE MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
RIGHT NOW WE SPEND HALF A
TRILLION DOLLARS ON MEDICARE FOR
18% OF THE POPULATION.
MULTIPLY THAT BY FIVE, WHICH IS
THE ENTIRE POPULATION, IT IS
$2.5 TRILLION A YEAR.
THAT WOULD BANKRUPT US.
IT WOULD ALSO LEAD TO THE
CLOSING OF ABOUT ONE-THIRD OF
OUR HOSPITALS BECAUSE MEDICARE
DOESN'T SUPPORT HOSPITALS.
PRIVATE INSURANCE DOES.
ONE-THIRD OF OUR HOSPITALS WILL
GO DOWN.
WE WOULD HAVE VERY POOR
COVERAGE.
IN ANOTHER NOT EVEN PAYING FOR
THEIR FREE TUITION WHICH WOULD
PROBABLY COST ANOTHER
2 TRILLION.
WOULD HAVE NOTHING LEFT FOR
DEFENSE OR ANYTHING ELSE THE
GOVERNMENT DOES AND THUS WE
MOVE THE TAX RATE TO 90%.
IT'S INSANE.
SO IF ONE OF THEM GETS THE
NOMINATION, I PRESERVE TONIGHT'S
DEBATE AND I PLAYED AGAINST THEM
AND SAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE A
BANKRUPT COUNTRY?
>> Laura: I WANT TO GET TO
SOMETHING ELSE BECAUSE RUDY JUST
MENTIONED A REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT.
I THINK IT DOMINATED THE ENTIRE
DEBATE.
WARREN AND BERNIE WERE KIND OF
PUT OFF TO THE LEFTIST CORNER
AND PEOPLE WERE SLIGHTLY MORE
MODERATE, MORE WILL REAL-WORLD
EXTREMES COME OVER AND OVER KEPT
EXPOSING THEM.
I DON'T KNOW IF CNN PLANNED IT
THIS WAY BUT THAT'S HOW IT WENT
DOWN.
THIS WAS WARREN AND BERNIE
DOUBLING DOWN, BASICALLY
THROWING OPEN OUR BORDERS AND
DANGLING A BUNCH OF FREE BEAST
UP FOR THE PEOPLE CROSSING THE
BORDER.
WATCH.
>> WOULD YOU DECRIMINALIZE
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSINGS?
>> YES.
THE POINT IS NOT ABOUT
CRIMINALIZATION.
THAT'S GIVEN DONALD TRUMP THE
TOOL.
SPEAK OF HER MOTHER AND HER
CHILD WALKED THOUSANDS OF MILESO
CHILD WALKED THOUSANDS OF MILESN
CHILD WALKED THOUSANDS OF MILESA
DANGEROUS PATH, IN MY VIEW, THEY
ARE NOT CRIMINALS.
>> Laura: SARA CARTER.
THIS IS DONALD TRUMP'S ISSUE.
CLEARLY WE HAVE A CRISIS OF THE
BORDER, EVEN WITH APPREHENSIONS
DOWN.
STILL UNBELIEVABLY HIGH NUMBER
OF PEOPLE COMING INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
THIS IS NOT WHERE MOST AMERICANS
ARE.
>> NO, THEY ARE COMPLETELY OFF
BASE.
MOST AMERICANS ARE NOT ON BOARD
WITH THIS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE IT
DECRIMINALIZE.
PEOPLE COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY,
WHAT'S THE OPTION?
IF ELIZABETH WARREN AND SHE
WANTS TO DECRIMINALIZE IT, IF
THAT HAPPENS, WHAT'S THE OPTION?
OPEN THE BORDERS FOR EVERYONE?
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO COME
IN HERE LEGALLY AND WHAT ABOUT
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE AFFECTED BY
THE DRUG CARTELS AND THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS THAT ARE BRINGING
THEM INTO THIS COUNTRY?
I AGREE WITH DELANEY AND OTHERS
AND I THINK THIS IS WHY THEY
WERE SO OSTRACIZED.
WE SEE SANDERS AND
ELIZABETH WARREN BEING PUSHED
ASIDE.
I ALMOST THINK IT WAS A TRAGEDY
BY THE REST OF THE TEAM TO
SAY THIS IS FANTASYLAND.
IF WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THESE
KINDS OF ISSUES THAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT, MEDICARE FOR ALL,
OPEN BORDERS FOR EVERYONE, WE'RE
GOING TO LOSE.
WE'RE GOING TO LOSE.
THEY ARE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
THEY WILL LOSE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO DOVETAIL
OVER FROM WHAT SARAH SAID.
NO, I WILL GO TO
GOVERNOR HUCKABEE FIRST.
THIS IS WHERE JOHN DELANEY, IN
THE 90s, STARTED A COUPLE
REALLY SUCCESSFUL COMPANIES,
HEALTH CARE COMPANIES.
SUPER SMART GUY.
HE HAD JUST ABOUT ENOUGH OF THE
PIE-IN-THE-SKY ARGUMENTS FROM
THE FAR LEFT OF THE PARTY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THE DATA IS CLEAR.
MEDICARE DOES NOT COVER THE
HEALTH OF POSTERIOR --
HEALTH CARE.
PRIVATE INSURANCE COVERS 100%.
I ASKED RURAL HOSPITAL
ADMINISTRATORS IF ALL YOUR BILLS
WERE PAID AT THE MEDICARE RATE
LAST YEAR, WHAT WOULD HAPPEN.
THEY ALL LOOK AT ME AND SAY WE
WOULD CLOSE.
>> Laura: THAT WAS A KILLER
MOMENT.
GOVERNOR HUCKABEE, YOUR REACTION
TO THE BUSINESSMAN, FORMER
CONGRESSMAN HITTING IT OUT OF
THE PARK.
>> WHAT IN THE HECK IS HE DOING
ON THAT STAGE WITH THOSE PEOPLE?
IT'S LIKE THAT PHOTO, WHICH ONE
OF THESE PEOPLE DOESN'T BELONG
IN THIS LINEUP.
IT'S DELANEY.
HE'S NOT A TRUMP FAN OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT BUT HE'S CLEARLY NOT
IN SYNC WITH THE REST OF THE
DEMOCRATIC FIELD OR THE REST OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU SOMETHING,
LAURA.
LET ME GO OUT ON A LIMB.
I THINK I MAY END UP ABANDONING
PRESIDENT TRUMP THIS NEXT
ELECTION CYCLE.
I'M GOING TO STAND WITH
MARIANNE.
SHE CAPTURED ME TONIGHT.
I LIT A CANDLE.
I STROKED A CRYSTAL.
I SAT BACK AND DECIDED TO TAKE A
YOGA POSE AND CHANT.
I COULD FEEL THE LOVE.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S AN INTERESTING STAGE.
I THINK SHE'S THE ONE WHO STANDS
OUT MORE THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
EVERY MEMBER WHERE I FIRST MET
HER.
IT WAS AT WOODSTOCK, THAT'S
WHERE IT WAS.
>> Laura: WERE YOU THERE?
I WOULD PAY TO SEE THAT.
RUDY, WOULDN'T YOU PAY TO SEE
HUCK AT WOODSTOCK?
>> I DON'T THINK HE WILL NUMBER
THIS BUT IN 2007 WHEN WE WERE
DEBATING, ONE TIME I WENT UP TO
HIM AND I SAID YOU BETTER DROP
OUT BECAUSE YOU ARE THE ONLY ONE
WHO KEEPS ME AWAKE DURING THE
DEBATE.
HE HAD THE BEST SENSE OF HUMOR.
THAT GUY IS UNBELIEVABLE.
THE REALITY IS THEY GOT CORNERED
AND DELANEY HAS NO CHANCE.
HE HELPED US A LOT TONIGHT BY
CORNERING THEM.
THINK OF THE IDEA OF LETTING
ANYBODY OVER THE BORDER WHO
WANTS TO COME IN.
MS-13, THE CARTELS, AND THE
TERRORISTS MUST'VE BEEN
APPLAUDING TONIGHT BECAUSE OF
THESE OTHER PEOPLE CAN COME IN,
THEY CAN COME IN WITH THEM.
WE'LL NEVER KNOW THEY'RE HERE
AND THEN THEY WILL GO KILL
PEOPLE IN ISLIP NEW YORK WHERE
THEY HAVE KILLED TOO MANY PEOPL
PEOPLE.
IT'S INSANE.
>> Laura: I AM FASCINATED,
LONGTIME DEMOCRAT POLLSTER, YOU
WATCHED THIS TONIGHT.
THE BIG DOGS ON THE STAGE,
BERNIE WHO HAD TO BE TOLD NOT TO
SHOUT AT LEAST ONCE.
AND WARREN WHO GOT INTO A WAR OF
WORDS WITH A COUPLE OF THE MORE
MODERATE FOLKS.
WE'LL GET INTO THAT.
YOUR TAKE ON HOW THIS ALL PLAYS
IN THE REAL WORLD, WHICH IS
AMERICA.
A LOT OF THIS DEBATE DOESN'T
ACTUALLY APPLY TO AMERICA.
IT'S LIKE THEY ARE RUNNING FOR
PRIME MINISTER OF SWEDEN, THIS
WOULD MAKE SENSE, SOME OF THESE
CONCEPTS WOULD MAKE SENSE BUT IN
AMERICA THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
GIVE UP THEIR GUNS.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE UP
THEIR CARS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GIVE UP
THEIR EMPLOYER-PROVIDED
INSURANCE.
IT'S NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
I AM BACK IN THE REAL WORLD.
>> LET'S REMEMBER THESE
CANDIDATES ARE TALKING TO A
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY AUDIENCE
WHICH IS A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
AUDIENCE THAN THE REST OF
AMERICA.
I THOUGHT THE MODERATES PUT ON A
GREAT SHOW AND THEY SHOWED SOME
OF THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN KIND
OF WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF SOME OF
THESE PROPOSALS REALLY GO INTO
THE GENERAL ELECTION.
I THINK REALLY ON THE STATE,
WHAT WAS HAPPENING, THERE'S A
FIGHT FOR THE PROGRESSIVE VOTE
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BERNIE SANDERS AND
ELIZABETH WARREN HAVE BEEN
BATTLING OUT FOR THAT AND
ELIZABETH WARREN REMARKABLY HAS
BEEN WINNING THAT FIGHT.
I THINK SHE COMES OUT OF THIS
DEBATE PROBABLY THE WINTER.
SHE CONSISTENTLY HIT THE BELLS
OF DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS.
BERNIE SANDERS IS CONTINUING TO
FADE.
THE MODERATES MADE A GOOD
ATTEMPT.
I DON'T THINK THEY GOT A LOT OF
TRACTION OUT OF IT.
I THINK SENATOR KLOBUCHAR ALSO
DID WELL, PARTICULARLY ON GUNS.
THIS IS NOT A DEBATE FOR
AMERICA.
THIS IS A DEBATE FOR DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY VOTERS AND I THINK QUITE
SURPRISINGLY WARREN IS GETTING
STRONGER AND STRONGER.
>> Laura: I WANT TO GO TO RUDY
ON THIS BECAUSE THERE WAS A
MOMENT WHERE THE PHRASE
"REPUBLICAN TALKING POINTS" WAS
USED AS THE DEMOCRATS TEND TO DO
THIS, MAYBE IT'S JUST A HUMAN
TRAIT.
YOU WANT TO AVOID A TOPIC SO YOU
EITHER ATTACK THE QUESTIONER OR
YOU SAY NO, THAT'S -- ACTUALLY
IT'S A SERIOUS QUESTION.
LET'S WATCH HOW THEY DEPLOYED
THIS.
>> WE SHOULD STOP USING...
>> Laura: SHE SAID WE SHOULD
STOP USING REPUBLICAN TALKING
POINTS.
WE HAD A GLITCH THERE.
WE WILL GET A BACKUP.
THAT WAS AND REPEATED BY TWO OR
THREE OTHERS AT DIFFERENT POINTS
THREE OTHERS AT DIFFERENT POINTI
THREE OTHERS AT DIFFERENT POINTN
THREE OTHERS AT DIFFERENT POINTT
THREE OTHERS AT DIFFERENT POINTA
THREE OTHERS AT DIFFERENT POINTD
THREE OTHERS AT DIFFERENT POINTB
THREE OTHERS AT DIFFERENT POINTT
THREE OTHERS AT DIFFERENT POINT.
JAKE TAPPER IS ASKING A QUESTION
ABOUT, ARE YOU GOING TO RAISE
TAXES ON THE MIDDLE CLASS,
REALLY GOOD QUESTION, MOST
EVERYONE DUCKED THE QUESTION
EXCEPT THEY KNOW WHO SAID NO.
SOMEHOW HE IS STILL POSING FOR
VOGUE SOMEWHERE.
RUDY, SAYING SOMETHING IS A
REPUBLICAN TALKING POINT, THAT'S
LIKE GIVING UP.
LIKE I GIVE UP.
>> IF RAISING TAXES IS A
REPUBLICAN TALKING POINT, THEN
THE ENTIRE MIDDLE CLOSES --
MIDDLE CLASS IS GOING TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN BECAUSE THEY DON'T WN
REPUBLICAN BECAUSE THEY DON'T WT
REPUBLICAN BECAUSE THEY DON'T WX
REPUBLICAN BECAUSE THEY DON'T WS
RAISED IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO DO
20% OF WHAT THEY TALKED ABOUT
TONIGHT WITHOUT RAISING TAXES.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
IT'S A COMPLETE FICTION THAT
THEY PRESENTED, AND I AGREE WITH
MARK PENN THAT PROBABLY IF YOU
THINK ABOUT JUST THE DEMOCRATIC
DOCTORATE, WARREN PROBABLY WON T
DOCTORATE, WARREN PROBABLY WON N
DOCTORATE, WARREN PROBABLY WON G
DOCTORATE, WARREN PROBABLY WON T
DOCTORATE, WARREN PROBABLY WON .
BECAUSE OF THE TWO CRAZY, CRAZY
SOCIALISTS, SHE WAS THE MORE
ARTICULATE, BETTER PREPARED, AND
IF I WERE SOCIALIST, I WOULD BET
ON HER RATHER THAN BERNIE.
BUT I WANT HER AS AN OPPONENT.
MY GOODNESS.
PEOPLE IN OHIO AND MICHIGAN IN
THAT PART OF THE COUNTRY THAT WE
HAVE TO WIN THAT HAS SENSIBLE
MIDDLE-CLASS PEOPLE, THEY HAD TO
BE FRIGHTENED OUT OF THEIR MINDS
LISTENING TO THIS.
>> Laura: YOU SEE PEOPLE LIKE
TIM RYAN AND EVEN, WHAT'S HIS
NAME FROM MONTANA, WHOSE NAME I
ALWAYS FORGET.
BULLOCK, OF COURSE.
YOU SEE DELANEY.
THEY COULD ALL BE IN TRUMP'S
CABINET.
ON THE TRADE QUESTION, WE ARE
GOING TO GET INTO IT LATER
BECAUSE IT HAPPENED LATE IN THE
DEBATE.
THE TRADE QUESTION, NONE OF THEM
CAN ANSWER THE TRADE QUESTION
BECAUSE TRUMP HAS KILLED IT ON
TRADE.
HE HAS DONE PHENOMENAL AND THEY
KNOW IT AND THEY ARE RELEGATED
SAYING WE SHOULDN'T DO ANY TRADE
DEALS.
BY THE END, THAT'S WHAT WARREN
WAS SING-ALONG WITH
BERNIE SANDERS.
HE IS SO -- TRUMP HAS SO BOX
THEM IN ON TRADE, THAT'S WHERE
THEY ARE.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE TRADE THE
INCOME IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
BERNIE SANDERS GOT INTO IT,
GOVERNOR HUCKABEE, WITH DELANEY
ON THE HEALTH CARE ISSUE WHERE
HE EXTOLLED THE VIRTUES OF
SOCIALIZED MEDICINE.
WATCH.
>> 5 MINUTES AWAY FROM HERE,
JOHN, IS A COUNTRY CALLED
CANADA.
THEY GUARANTEE HEALTH CARE TO
EVERY MAN, WOMAN, AND CHILD AS A
HUMAN RIGHT.
THEY SPEND HALF OF WHAT WE SPENT
AND BY THE WAY, WHEN YOU END UP
IN A HOSPITAL IN CANADA, YOU
COME OUT WITH NO BILL AT ALL.
>> Laura: BERNIE NEEDS TO
CHECK HIS FACTS BECAUSE
ACCORDING TO THE CANADIAN PUBLIC
POLICY THINK TANK THE FRASER
INSTITUTE, OVER 63,000 CANADIANS
GOT MEDICAL CARE OUTSIDE THE
COUNTRY IN 2017, LARGELY
DUE TO WAIT TIMES.
THE SAME GROUP REPORTS THAT IN
2018 MANY RESIDENTS HAD TO WAIT
AN AVERAGE OF 20 WEEKS TO
ACTUALLY GET A TREATMENT.
GOVERNOR, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> A COUPLE POINTS.
FIRST OF ALL, I THOUGHT DELANEY
MADE A GREAT POINT WHEN HE
MENTIONED THAT WOULD BERNIE
WANTS TO DO IS NOT SO MUCH GIVE
PEOPLE HEALTH CARE BUT TAKE IT
AWAY FOR 180 MILLION PEOPLE WHO
CURRENTLY HAVE IT.
HE SAID IF WE APPROACH TO
SOCIAL SECURITY LIKE THAT AND
SAID WE ARE GOING TO GET RID OF
SOCIAL SECURITY AND GIVE YOU
SOME OTHER KIND OF DEAL, IF
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE THAT AWAY
FROM YOU, YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
SOMETHING AWAY TO GIVE PEOPLE
SOMETHING YOU DON'T HAVE IT.
THAT WAS A GREAT POINT.
THE SECOND OBSERVATION IS I
THINK WE WERE THIS CLOSE TO
SEEING BERNIE LOOK OUT THERE ON
THE STAGE AND JUST SAY GET OFF
MY LAWN.
THIS IS ONE ANGRY MAN.
HE'S LIKE THE GREAT UNCLE, THE
CURMUDGEON, WHO JUST NEEDS TO
CALM DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
HE IS SO ANGRY.
NUMBER ONE RULE THAT YOU NEED TO
BE AS A CANDIDATE, YOU'VE GOT TO
HAVE SOME LEVEL OF LIKABILITY TO
WIN A GENERAL ELECTION.
MAYBE NOT THE PRIMARY BUT IN THE
GENERAL, YOU HAVE TO BE LIKABLE
TO SOMEBODY.
>> Laura: "SESAME STREET,"
STATLER AND WALDORF, THOSE GUYS
YELLING AT PEOPLE.
HE DID GET A LITTLE HEATED A FEW
TIMES TONIGHT AND WE'LL HAVE
SARA CARTER AND MARK TAKE A
GANDER AT THIS.
WATCH.
>> I THINK IF WE'RE GOING TO
FORCE AMERICANS TO MAKE THESE
RADICAL CHANGES, THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO GO ALONG.
THROW YOUR HANDS UP BUT --
>> THIS IS NOT RADICAL.
THIS IS WHAT VIRTUALLY EVERY
OTHER COUNTRY ON EARTH DOES.
>> WELCOME TO YOU IN A SECOND.
YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> I DO.
I WROTE THE DAMN BILL.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO YELL.
>> Laura: SHOULD WE BE WORRIED
ABOUT BERNIE'S DEMEANOR?
>> PERSONALITY.
>> Laura: IT'S KIND OF FUN.
EVERYTHING IS LIKE A --
>> JACKIE MASON.
>> Laura: THERE'S NO TONALITY
CHANGE.
IT'S ALL ONE NOTE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I WROTE THE DAMN BILL.
EVERYONE SAID THAT WAS THE LINE
OF THE NIGHT.
BERNIE STOLE THE SHOW.
HE'S LIKE THE UNCLE WHO COMES
OVER TO DINNER AND EVERYBODY'S
WORRIED, DON'T UPSET UNCLE
BERNIE.
HE'S GOING TO GO OFF ON YOU.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW IF THIS IS
GOING TO WORK FOR HIM, LAURA.
IT NEVER REALLY HAS IN THE PAST.
YOU ALSO NEED THE DEMEANOR.
AS A POLITICIAN.
STRANGER THINGS HAVE HAPPENED,
AND WE HAVE A HUGE DEMOGRAPHIC
OF YOUNG PEOPLE, MILLENNIALS AND
OTHERS, PEOPLE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
SOCIALISM AND THESE IDEAS, THESE
PROGRESSIVE IDEAS, HAVE KIND OF
SEEPED INTO THE SYSTEM AND THEY
LOOKED TOWARDS BERNIE SANDERS.
I DON'T THINK HE SHOULD BE
DISMISSED.
I ACTUALLY THINK WE HAVE TO KEEP
AN OPEN MIND AND REALLY SAY HE
COULD POSSIBLY BE A CONTENDER.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW YET.
>> HE COULD BE A CONTENDER!
>> Laura: MARK PENN.
I'M GOING TO JUST DO
IMPERSONATIONS.
>> I COULD'VE BEEN A CONTENDER!
"ON THE WATERFRONT."
>> "ON THE BORDER."
>> Laura: YOU ALL KNOW WHAT
I'M THINKING.
NOW WE ARE GETTING OUT OF HAND.
MARK PENN, IN ALL SERIOUSNESS,
HE'S A SENATOR FROM VERMONT.
HEATH FEELS PRETTY BIG VENUES.
HE HAS A VERY LOYAL FOLLOWING.
HE DOES COME ACROSS AS A BIT OF
A HECTOR.
WE TEND TO LIKE HAPPY WARRIORS,
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME WHEN THE
COUNTRY IS DOING PRETTY WELL.
WE HAVE STUFF WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH BUT WE ARE DOING PRETTY
WELL.
THE HECTORING THING SEEMS A
LITTLE OFF.
IT DOESN'T SEEM ALL THAT
APPROACHABLE.
MAYBE THAT'S WHERE THE DEMOCRATS
ARE.
>> THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
BERNIE SANDERS WHO WON FOUR
YEARS AGO IN BERNIE SANDERS
TODAY.
BERNIE SANDERS AFTER THE
ELECTION WAS ONE OF THE MOST
BELOVED PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE, REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE AGREED
WITH HIS VIEWS ON SOCIALISM.
THEY STILL LIKED HIM.
THEY LIKED HIM AS EVERYBODY'S
UNCLE.
THE POLLING NUMBERS WERE QUITE
REMARKABLE.
IF YOU LOOK IN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS, HE'S BEEN GOING DOWN
VIRTUALLY EVERY MONTH BECAUSE
BERNIE SANDERS 2 ISN'T WEARING
VERY WELL.
HE'S NOT IN THE TECHNOLOGICAL
AGE WITH HIS ISSUES.
HE IS REPEATING A SIMILAR WRAP,
ALTHOUGH HE'S CHANGED IT A
LITTLE BIT TO BE SOMEWHAT MORE
ABOUT DIVERSITY.
HE HASN'T HAD A REALLY MUCH
APPEAL OVER INTO THE MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
AND AS I TELL YOU, IF SANDERS
AND WARREN BOTH SPLIT THE
PROGRESSIVE VOTE, THAN ACTUALLY
IT'LL MAKE IT EASIER FOR A
MODERATE TO WIN.
THEY EACH KNOW THAT.
ONE OF THEM HAS TO KNOCK OUT THE
OTHER, OR THEY ARE BOTH GOING TO
SPLIT THE VOTE AND THEY KNOW
THAT.
>> Laura: I THINK THAT HE AND
BETO SHOULD HAVE A .-OFFERED
HOOP POINTS BETTER.
BERNIE DOES THE FAST POINT AND
BETO DOES THE POINT THAT DOESN'T
REALLY GO WITH WHAT HE IS
SAYING.
IT'S A BIG POINT OF JUST A
CHELATION.
DEMOCRAT VOTERS ARE REPEATEDLY
SAYING AND MARK KNOWS THIS, THEY
DON'T REALLY CARE THAT MUCH OF
THE CANDIDATE MESHES WITH ALL
THEIR VIEWS.
THEY WANT TO BEAT TRUMP.
THAT IS THE GOLDEN GOOSE THEY
HAVE TO GET.
THEY WANT TO BEAT TRUMP.
THEY WILL MAKE COMPROMISES AS
LONG AS IT'S A CANDIDATE WHO CAN
BEAT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE HEAD-TO-HEAD POLLS, WHICH I
DON'T PUT MUCH STOCK IN, THEY
ALL SAY THEY ARE ALL GOING TO
BEAT TRUMP.
THEY KIND OF PUT ASIDE THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE ISSUES FOR
WIND ABILITY.
YOUR THOUGHT.
>> I THINK SANDERS AND WARREN
DON'T AGREE WITH THAT.
THEY WERE TRYING TO MAKE AN
APPEAL TONIGHT TO DEMOCRATS TO
VOTE FOR WHAT THEY BELIEVE IN.
NOT ON THE PRACTICAL THEORY OF
WHO CAN WIN.
I THINK IT'S TOO EARLY TO FIGURE
THAT OUT.
BUT I THINK WOULD BE UNREALISTIC
IF WE DIDN'T THINK IT'S COME
DOWN TO FOUR PEOPLE.
IT'S BERNIE, WARREN, BIDEN,
HARRIS.
IT WOULD BE REALLY HARD FOR
ANYBODY ELSE TO BREAK INTO THAT.
I THINK THOSE ARE THE FOUR WE
ARE DEALING WITH.
AND I THINK BIDEN PROBABLY GAINS
TONIGHT IF HE CAN HAVE A DECENT
PERFORMANCE TOMORROW NIGHT.
>> Laura: I COMPLETELY AGREE.
>> HE IS THE ONE THAT NATURALLY
PEOPLE WOULD THINK OF AS A
MODERATE.
HOWEVER, BIDEN HAS BEEN RUNNING
TO PRETEND THAT HE CAN
OUT-SOCIALIST ALL OF THEM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT JOE'S THEORY
IS BUT HE WOULD ORDINARILY BE
THE ONE THAT WOULD HAVE WON
TONIGHT, EXCEPT FOR THE WAY HE'S
RUNNING IN POSTURING HIMSELF.
WE WILL SEE TOMORROW NIGHT.
IF HARRIS WIPES THEM OUT
TOMORROW NIGHT, THE WAY SHE DID